[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
نيبالو علاقه وطيبه بحوادث الطيران
السلطات تعلن عن 67 قتيلا من اصل 72 في
تحطم طائره
ارتفاع ملحوظ للتضخم في السعوديه اسعار
الايجار السبب الاكبر والتعليم
خلال العام الماضي انخفاض طفيف لمعدلات
الاكتئاب في السعوديه
الدخل الاقل والتدخين ابرز اسبابه
الرابعه ايضا
ترقب لنهائي السوبر الاسباني في الرياض
ريال مدريد يلتقي برشلونه في كلاسيكو
الارض
اعلانات شرطه نيباليه مصرع 67 شخصا على
الاقل جراء تحطم الطائره ركاب كان على
مترها 72 شخصا في مدينه بخارى السياحيه
وقالت هيئه الطيران المدني النيباليه في
بيان من الطائره كانت ذات محركين من طراز
اي تي ار 72 التي تديرها شركه ريتال جويه
نيباليه بدوله يوضح رئيس الوزراء
بوشبه كمال
الطائره كانت في طريقها من العاصمه
كتماندو الى مدينه بخارى وسط نيبال فيما
لم يتضح بعد سبب تحطم الطائره يذكره ان
مدينه بخارى تعد مسارا شهيرا للترحال
لمسافات طويله في جبال الهملايا كان مطار
بخار الدولي بدا عملياته منذ اسبوعين فقط
بحسب قاعده سلامه الطيران التابعه لمؤسسه
سلامه الطيران فقد وقع 48
حادثا مميتا مماثا في نيبال منذ عام 19 اه
سته واربعين
من القاهره ينضم الينا محمود القطه الطيار
وخبير السلامه الجوي سيد محمود اهلا وسهلا
بك معي من ضمن الاثنين واربعين حادث التي
وقعت حسب الاحصائيه كانت هناك احدى عشره
حادثه الطيران وقعت خلال عشر سنوات او اقل
تقريبا لماذا تكثر حوادث الطيران بهذا
الشكل في نيبال تحديدا والى اي حد اصبح
الامر مقلقا
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين طبعا ده حادث ماساوي راحت فيه
حاجه كثير
نبال للاسف الشديد سريعه الحرب في مجال
الطيران ما هي ليست لديها
الاجهزه المتقدمه في مجال الملاحه الجويه
وهذا الامر مثبت او معوض لها في عديد من
المحاولات في تطوير الطيران في جهود
بتتعمل فعلا في جبال لتطوير الطيران ولكن
ليست هناك الامكانيات ومقومات اللازمه
اللي تخليها ادرى ان هي تواكب العصر
الحديث تبان من الدول التي بها مناخ
استوائي
الاجواء الظواهر الجويه بها متعدده من
امطار واواصل الى ذلك ايضا همم هي الارض
بها ليست مسطحه همم بشكل الكافي الذي يجعل
الطيران بها من النوع السهل ولكن هي بها
العديد الهدوء والسهول مما يستلزم ان يكون
لكي تضمن سلامه الطيران ان يكون بها اجهزه
حديثه وان يكون هناك بها معدات ملاحيه
حديثه وايضا هناك انواع مختلفه من التدريب
سواء للملاحه الجويه والمراقبه الجويه
ولطيرين ايضا الذين يهبطون في الاراضي
النيباليه همم ايضا طرزات الطائرات تحتاج
انواع معينه من طرزان الطائرات التي على
سبيل المثال احد انواعها هي طائره التي
حدثت لها الحاجه اليوم في يتناسب المناسبه
هو مناسب للهبوط في الاراضي النيباليه همم
ولكن همم من المشهد الاول نجد ان هناك همم
خلدا ما لا ندري همم شكله او طبيعته حتى
الان همم ادى الى ان تصل الى هذا الحادث
يعني ان تترجح ان يكون ربما همم
الاهمال عدم التركيز من قبل الموظفين
مساله طائرات هي السبب او الاسباب الاكثر
ترجيحا لتكرار حوادث الطيران وليست طقس او
التضاريس كما يرى الكثير
هو الحقيقه اذا زي ما اشرت في الاول هو
الطقس والتضاريس هو بالفعل احد العوامل
المؤثره همم على همم جوده الطيران في نبال
وهذا يستلزم ان يكون هناك العنصر البشري
والعنصر التكنولوجي اعلى او يختلف كثيرا
في قدراته وامكانياته عن الظروف العاديه
هذا لم يتوفر حتى الان فهل العنصر البشري
هو اا احد اسباب الحادث الاخير هذا متوقع
همم بشده ولكن ننتظر طبعا التحقيقات
النهائيه لان هذا امر مهم ولكن همم
حاولنا البحث بعد وقوع الحادث ال- ال-
الجو في هذا الوقت لم يكن بالسوق الذي همم
يؤدي الى ان يكون هناك ظاهره طبيعيه همم
المطار صحيح ومطار حديث ولكن حركه الطيران
في ليست كبيره ولكنها في نفس الوقت هي
اعتياديه
ومن متوسطه الى همم الخفيفه همم همم
المناوره التي قام بها الطيار قبل
السقوط او قبل همم الحادث همم يعني توحي
بانه كان هناك محاوله همم او كان يتم
توجيهه ليقوم بالنزول بامان ولكن هناك حدث
عارض لا ندري ما هو حتى
يبدا نفقدنا الاتصال بضيفنا من القاهره
عموما نكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا
لمحمود الطيار والخبير في السلام الجويه
في تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عشان نتعددا من الضربات
الصاروخيه على مواقع
السلطات الاوكرانيه بمقتل 21 شخصا على
الاقل بسبب القصف الروسيه على مجمع السكني
في
[تصفيق]
رئيس الروسيه
الايجابيه للعمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
لان الهجوم على اوكرانيا ياسر
الروسي مستقر بل هو افضل من التوقعات
لافتا الى ان معدل التضخم والبطاله في
الخطاب
قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا
تدرس رفع سن التجنيد الى 30 عاما وفي
تحديثها الاستخبارات اليوميه اضافت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه بان رئيس لجنه الدفاع
في مجلس الدومه روسي اندري كارت بولوف
اقترح مؤخرا ان تمدد روسيا سن الاقصى
للتجنيد العسكري من 27 الى 30 عاما وذلك
في المسوده المقترحه خلال الاشهر المقبله
البريطانيه معلومات تفيد بان بريطانيا
سترسل اربعه مروحيات قتاليه من نوع اباتشي
الى اوكرانيا ضمن حزمتي مساعدتي نقلت
صحيفه عن مصدر عسكري رفيع المستوى قوله ان
المروحيات ستكون ضمن حزمه من عشر دبابات
شالنجر اثنين وسيتم تسليمها لاوكرانيا
قريبا ولم يصدر اي بيان او تاكيد لهذه
المعلومه سواء من وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
او نظيرتها الاوكرانيه
نشرت صحيفه نيوز ويك تايمز ما قالت انه
ادله تكشف اساليب روسيا الى التفافها على
العقوبات الاقتصاديه الغربيه وذلك عبر
بوابات الدول المجاوره
اقتصاد روسيا في زمن الحرب اظهر قدرتها
السريعه على التاقلمي مع المستجدات رغم
توقعات غربيه بانهيارها سريعا في ظل
عقوبات عزلتها عن العالم
كيفيه حصول ذلك
صحيفه نيويورك الى ان روسيا تحايلت على
منع العديد من البضائع الغربيه من الوصول
اليها
فعلى مدى الاشهر العشره الماضيه برزت
جورجيا قناه اللوجستيه المريحه بين روسيا
والعالم الخارجي
فما تحتاجه يتدفق اليها عبر الطريق شاحنات
بطيء ومزتحم يمر في جبال القوقاز بحسب صور
نشرتها الصحيفه
كل يومين تعبر قافله من الشاحنات على طول
طريق جبلي سريع من جورجيا نحو الحدود مع
روسيا رحله تبدا اعاده من تركيا وتنتهي في
البلدات والمدن الروسيه حيث يزداد الطلب
على السلع الغربيه
تضاعف حجمه عبور البضائع بين تركيا وروسيا
ثلاث مرات خلال الاشهر السته الاولى من
العام الماضي جرى نقل الكثير منها على
الطريق الجورجيه وفقا لبحث اجره بنك تي بي
سي كابيتال الاستثماري والرائد في جورجيا
تغيير استراتيجيه روسيا لسد حاجاتها
الاساسيه بالحصول على بضائع من دول مجاوره
اخرى مثل ارمينيا واذربيجان ساعد موسكو
على التغلب على العاصفه الاقتصاديه
الناجمه عن حربها على اوكرانيا وفقا
لصحيفه نيورك تايمز التي قالت انه من
المستحيل معرفه مقدار البضائع الاوروبيه
العابره لروسيا والخاضعه لعقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبيه لكنه ظهور جورجيا كحلقه من
رئيسيه في التجاره مع موسكو يوصل للضوء
على ثغره المحتمله في سياسه العقوبات
الغربيه
روان حمزه العربيه
بعد قليل
مكافحه الفساد في الكويت
تتواصل حبس وكيل سابق في وزاره الاوقاف
وثلاثه موظفين سبع سنوات
اهلا بكم من جديد في الكويت قدت محكمه
التمييز بحبس وكيل مسابقه في وزاره
الاوقاف وثلاثه موظفين اخرين بينهم وافد
سبع سنوات
وتسهيل الاستيلاء على المال العام من
اموال الهيئه الخيريه العالميه هذا وكانت
نيابه العامه حققت مع المتهمين بتهمه
الاستيلاء على المال العام وطالبت
بمعاقبتهم جميعا
سجل مؤشر الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
في السعوديه لشهر ديسمبر 2002 و20 ارتفاع
عن قدره نسبته 33 من 10% مقارنه بالعام
الماضي 2021
ارتفاع الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
يعزى بدوره الارتفاع اسعار السكن والمياه
والكهرباء والغاز وانواع الوقود بالنسبه
تصل الى خمسه وتسعه من العشره في المئه في
المرتفع اسعار الاغذيه والمشروبات بالنسبه
اربعه فاصل اثنين من ال 10%
تفاصيل اكثر حول الارقام التضخم في
السعوديه نستعرضها مع العنود العبدلي
دول العالم حيث ارتفع معدل التضخم او ما
يسمى بمؤشر الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
بنسبه
33% في ديسمبر 20 22 مقارنه بنفس الفتره
من عام 20 21 اسعار الايجارات المرتفعه هي
المؤثر الاكبر في زياده التضخم كاد خلال
ديسمبر الماضي وفقا لهيئه الاحصاء
السعوديه الارتفاع الاضخم مشاهدينا كان في
اسعار ايجارات الشقق حيث بلغ اكثر من
ثمانيه عشره في المئه خلال ديسمبر الماضي
على اساسن سنوي خدمات الاغذيه والنقل
والمطاعم والفنادق سجلتها الاخرى ارتفاعا
ملحوضا ونشاهده في الرسم البياني ارتفاع
اسعار قسم الاغذيه والمشروبات بنسبه
24% في مساج الوقت في ما سجل قطاع نقل
ارتفاعا باكثر من اربعه في المئه في
امبارح عشرين اثنين وعشرين اما قسموا
المطاعم والفنادق شهد ارتفاعا في الاسعار
بنسبه 86 اعشار في المئه خلال الذات
الفتره مقارنه بالعام 20 21 قطاع التعليم
في جميع مراحله طاله التضخم ايضا خلال
ديسمبر الماضي وفقا لبنات الهيئه الاحصاء
في السعوديه التي كشفت ارتفاع اسعار خدمات
التعليم في المجمل بنسبه ثلاثه وسته اعشار
في المئه ويعود هذا الارتفاع الى التغير
في اسعار التعليم ما قبل ابتدائي والتعلم
الابتدائي
فيديوهات من الرياضه المحاله الاقتصادي
محمد الامور استاذ محمد حياك الله في 2022
كان متوسط التضخم اثنين فاصله خمسه من
العشره ثم ارتفع في نوفمبر الى 2.9 اليوم
نتكلم عن
3.3 خلال هذا في ديسمبر ارتفاع هل يمكن
القول بانه في حدود المنطقي المعقول
المتحكم بامير بالقلب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يعني ارتفاع مقلق لا لا شكلك لكن
لا ننسى ان تضخم هي مشكله عالميه يعني
تعتبر حاليا من اهم التحديات الاقتصاديه
التي تواجه العالم كله لكن بالنسبه
للمملكه تظل هي من ادنى المعدلات همم تضخم
ايضا قراناها مع دول مجموعه العشرين او
حتى مع بقيه الدول العالم تعتبر هي الاقل
يعني بين دول العالم
وبراينا طبعا سبب رئيسي وارتفاع اسعار
السلعه عالميا وتفاقم الوضع للاسوء مع
الحرب الروسيه
عل اسعار المحاصيل الزراعيه القمح الذره
الشعير وايضا الاسعار الاسمده مما ادى الى
انها ظهرت ازمه عالميه في الحقيقه لكن
طبعا بالنسبه للمملكه تظل نوجه نظريه تحت
السيطره همم عاده في مثل هذه الامور
الجهات المسؤوله من اهمها طبعا البنك
المركزي
يحدون من التضخم بالتحكم بسعر الفائده مثل
ما معروف اسعار الفائده الان على الريال
السعودي مرتفع بشكل قوي جدا صحيح احنا
ممكن تؤثر على نمو القطاع الخاص نسبيا
وتحد من همم يعني نمو ولكن يعني بالتاكيد
من ايجابيات رفع الفائده هو الحد من
التضخم وبالتالي اليوم اسعار الفائده احنا
نتكلم بين 4:30 الى 5% الريمبو العكسي مع
الريبو يعني معدلات اعلى من التضخم اللي
هو ثلاثه ثلاثه
هذا يعني
ثلاثه ثلاثه كان في اربع من العشره جالسين
الدوري
او سنتين يعني يرتفعنا فوق ال 6% في اغسطس
20 20 وايضا في يونيو 20 21 كنا فوق مستوى
6% لكن طبعا تباطا بعدها بسبب طبعا
الاداره الاقتصاديه الاحترافيه
الاقتصاد المملكه وبالتالي نزلنا الى
مستويات قرب الصفر تقريبا يعني الان صحيح
ان مرتفع طبعا السبب الرئيسي داخليا مرتفع
بشكل غير مباشره
واحد من الاسباب الرئيسي
المطاعم الاغذيه والمشروبات السكن تحديدا
التاجير يعني هو اللي ارتفع بشكل كبير
طبعا بسبب ارتفاع اسعار المساكن لان اسعار
الايجار مرتبطه بشكل غير مباشر بارتفاع
الوحده السكنيه نفسها وقيمتها ايضا النقل
كلها المؤشرات هذه مع الاسف معدلات اعلى
من ثلاثه فاصله ثلاثه في المئه وهي اللي
السبب الرئيسي في هذا الارتفاع
همم استاذ محمد يعني طبعا ما في شك ان هي
تضخم مستورد بين الدرجه الاولى بسبب اسعار
السلع الزراعيه المستورده بالدرجه الاولى
اضافه طبعا الى لابد من تقنين سلوك
المستهلك يعني لما نشوف افراط في استخدام
همم الانثاق الاستهلاكي تجاه المشروبات
والاغذيه والمطاعم بشكل في الحقيقه احنا
نفسنا
اجتماعيا فعلا ظاهره يعني غير طبيعي
لكن يعني في سلوك غير عقلاني في هذا
الجانب اذا تم السيطره على هذا السلوك
بالتاكيد انه هيحد على جزء كبير من هذا
المشكله تحديدا فيما يتعلق بالمطعم اسعار
المطاعم واسعار المشروبات
هل يؤثر بشكل او باخر على القوه الشرائيه
الموجوده خلينا نتكلم
لكن هل هي يعني متوائمه مع هذا الارتفاع
العدو اللدود لاي اقتصاد ودائما اي
اقتصاديين في اي حكومه حول العالم يحاولون
الحد من التضخم يعني لان يمثل ارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشه يمثل تاكل قيمه العمله
المحليه لاي دوله حول العالم طبعا
بالتاكيد هو مرتبط يعني لما نتكلم عن
الانفاق الاستهلاكي مرتبط بالقوه الشرائيه
للافراد ايضا فبالتاكيد اذا استمر التضخم
بالارتفاع بالتاكيد الناحيه ياثر على
القوه الشرائيه المتاحه للانفاق
الاستهلاكي وطبعا لا نشاهدها بشكل سريع
يعني تحتاج بعض الوقت حتى نشوف تاثيراتها
على القوه الشرائيه
المتوقع انه نشهد ارتفاعات اكبر بالاسعار
لمرتبطه كذلك يمكن دائما تعريف ارتفاع
التضخم والتضخم هو مرتبط دائما بالاسعار
فهل من المتوقع نشهد كذلك ارتفاعا مازالت
الظروف نفسها موجوده ربما كذلك تتفاقم
يعني خلال الفترات القادمه ربطها في معدل
ارتفاع التضخمين ممكن يوصل بشكل كبير على
الوضع العالمي اسعار المواد الغذائيه
والسلع الزراعيه والاسمده لان هذا هو
المحرك الرئيسي لانه مثل ما قلنا هو تضخم
مستورد هو ليس يعني بسبب الطلب المحلي
الان مؤثر ناقته والبنك المركزي في
المملكه قاعد يقوم بدور جبار في الحقيقه
بارتفاع اسعار الفائده مثل ما قلنا ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده لها اضرار على النمو
الاقتصادي لكن ايضا لها ايجابيات على
التحكم في الطبخ واعتقد الان في ظل اسعار
الفائده بالريال السعودي اعلى من معدلات
الرقم هذا مؤشرات انها باذن يعني الامور
تحت السيطره لكن طبعا الاعوام الخارجيه
مهم جدا ان نشوف لها تهدئه واعتقد ايضا
البنوك اليوم
يعني الجهات المسؤوله في مواجهه التضخم مع
استمرار الحرب وكل يعني نتائج على كل
المستويات بالتالي ما الاجراءات الاخرى
التي يجب النظر اليها اليوم لمواجهته للحد
من التضخم بعيدا عن الفائده ورفع سعر
الفائده اللي ذكرته انك واحد من العوامل
المهم ومع الاسف يعني
قدامك اسعار الفائده وقدامك اسعار الصرف
يعني طبعا هذه اسعار الصرف لا يمكن المساس
بها باي حال من الاحوال وايضا سعر الفائده
ما زالت يعني البنك المركزي يقوم بدورات
المهم هو العامل الخارجيه طبعا في جهود
كثيره في همم يعني الاعتماد على المصادر
الذاتيه يعني همم لكن طبعا مثل ما معروف
همم في جهود كبيره باستراد ال- ال- المواد
الزراعي المنتجات الزراعيه من مصادر
للاستثمارات العامه واستثمرت جزء كبير
فيها هذا هيلعب دور كبير بالتاكيد بالحد
من ارتفاع اسعار
الزراعيه لكن في النهايه احنا جزء من
منظومه عالميه لابد ان يعني العوامل
الخارجيه هي اللي تلعب دور في الاجاره
محمد العمران الاقتصادي شكرا جزيلا لكم
حياك الله شكرا
في محافظه تعز اليمنيه كان الطفل امير
العامري دول اربع سنوات احد الضحايا الغام
ميليشيا الحوتي التي تسببت ببتري ساقه
ووفاه عمه وابن عمه تبع قصته في التقرير
الثاني
قتلت احلامى اقرب وصفا لسان حال الطفل
اليمني امير الذي بترت ساقه نتيجه رغم
الحوثي وهو لم يتجاوز عامه الرابعه كذلك
هنا في محافظه تعز ترك لهم الطفل امير
شريف العامري اسيرا للاعاقه بعد ان تسبب
في بتر ساقه ولم يكتفي بذلك بل قتل عمه
وابن عمه شريكا اللعب حينها
هذا وابن عمه
على طول الاب
دخل الشضايا الى داخل البيت انتهى على طول
ان تضع هذه الالغام في طريق الاطفال
والنساء والمدنيين في رحلتهم اليوميه لكسب
رزقهم
من الجرائم الحرب لانه انت داري في هذا حي
سكاني اطفال ونساء وطبعا الماء ولا اكثرهم
معاهم اغنام معتمدين على الحطب ضروري ما
يخرجه
هذاك الطريقه
[موسيقى]
الف خير
وبينما يد الحوثي تزرع هذه الالغام هناك
يد اخرى تنزعها تتمثل في مشروع مسام لنزع
الالغام في اليمن الذي نزع منذ انطلاقه في
يوليو 2018 وحتى نهايه العام الماضي نحو
380,000 من الالغام والذخائر غير المتفجره
والعبوات الناسفه
الرابعه مستمره ايضا فيها بعد قليل
خلال العام الماضي انخفاض طفيف لمعدلات
الاكتئاب في السعوديه دخلوا الاقل
والتدخين برزوا اسبابه
اهلا بكم من جديد معدلات اقل الاكتئاب
سجلتها السعوديه خلال العام الماضي مقارنه
بعام الجائع 20 20 حيث كشف المركز الوطني
لتعزيز الصحه النفسيه عن انخفاض معدل
الاكتئاب من
13.8% الى 12.7 من العاشره
تعزيز الصحه النفسيه في السعوديه ان مؤشر
القلق ارتفع بشكل طبيب مقارنه بالعمده
وفقا لاحدث الدراسات فان الاناث معروضات
بشكل اكبر لاصابه باعراض القلق العام منها
عند الرجال وحول اسباب ارتفاع معدل
الاكتئاب اوضح المركزه انخفاض معدل داخل
الى اقل من خمسه الاف ريال سعودي بالاضافه
الى ممارسه العاده التدخين بمختلف في
انواعه من الاسباب الرئيسيه
اهلا وسهلا كيف حالك
الدكتوره حياك الله مع الدكتوره لمياء
الابراهيم الكاتبه الصحفيه حياك الله
دكتوره
راقبك راقب حركات جسدك هل فيها علامات
اكتئاب
ما شاء الله
طفيف جدا
لما نتكلم عن واحد تقريبا
هل هذا الانخفاض مطمئن ولا يبعث على القلق
بشكل اكبر
طيب بشكل عام احنا
تطورت اليه المسح سواء كانت من ناحيه
الاكتئاب او حتى القلق تطور الوعي بالنسبه
للناس حتى انهم بيعرفوا انه عندهم مشاكل
ترتبط بالقلق الاطفال نفسهم لا هذه صار
عندهم وعي انهم يذهبون باطفالهم الى
الاخصائي النفسي او المرشد النفسي او طبيب
الاسره حتى انهم يستشيروا في وضع ابنائهم
وبالتالي يمكن تشخيص القلق او الاكتئاب في
او الامراض النفسيه بشكل عام تشخيصها بشكل
اسرع الضغوط اللي كانت تمر على الناس سواء
كانت في سبب او حتى ما بعد الجائحه قلق
المكان
والصراعات على المكانه قلق الاستحقاقيه
وتقدير الذات قلق حتى لما انه الشكل همم
الظروف بشكل عام لما تكلمت حتى على المراه
يعني حتى من ناحيه مثلا السوشيال ميديا
وتاثير السوشيال ميديا والتنافسيه هذه
زياده همم يعني احد الاسباب انه زادت
المقارنه يعني سابقا كان الناس تقارن
نفسها بمحيطها المباشر حاليا تقدر تقارن
نفسها بالعالم كله بشكل عام لماذا هذا
الشخص عندي وان هذا الشخص وانا ما عندي
همم البطاله لها دور
بنتكلم عن التضخم وارتفاع الاسعار
بين الناس التي تعيش في المدن وبين الناس
تعيش في الكره او الهجر او بالناس اللي
تعيش في المناطق المائيه والمناطق الجبليه
هنالك عوامل كثيره ولكن احد الاسباب الى
هذه المساله وتطور اليه الماس والوصول الى
فئه كبيره من المجتمع نحن لا نتكلم عن
التشخيص يعني حتى لو احنا نتكلم عن
التشخيص لها معايير معينه تكلم ماذا بعد
التشخيص ماذا بعد هذه العلاقات
الان كيف انا اعرف انه انا عندي اكتئاب
ولا لا اليوم الملاحظ انه في كثير من
الصفحات والمواقع وغيره تضع اسئله معينه
الاجابه عليها ممكن تحطنا في درجه من
درجات الاكتئاب خفيف متوسط حاد ما ادري
ايش يعني فبالتالي هل يمكن الركوب
الاسئله اللي ممكن من خلالها احدد انه انا
مريض ولا لا بالاكتئاب ومتى يكون خطر وكيف
ممكن نتعامل معاه بشكل اكتئاب مرض
نفسيز لما يدخل في مرحله الاضطراب يعني
ممكن ان يكون احباط حاله مؤقته من اي سبب
من الاسباب لما يتطور الموضوع انه يكون
اكثر تقريبا من سته اشهر يعني بحاله مزمنه
يمكن ثلاث مرات في الاسبوع دائما الانسان
يكون عنده فكره معينه لها يعني لتشخيص
الاكتئاب وكذلك هي تشخيص القلق لما تطول
على فتره على سته اشهر من الانسان دائما
بيكون في حاله انه همم حزين همم
يميل الى البكاء همم الاشياء اللي تمتعوا
في السابق لا تمتعوا في الوقت الراهن تظهر
على ربما اعراض جسديه مختلفه منها لا بد
ان يذهب الى الطبيب الذي يستطيع من خلال
الاسئله ومن خلال تشخيص الاعراض ان يصل
الى همم تقريب التجهيز وليس التشخيص
النهائي حتى يتاكد هل ما في هذه اعراض هي
نفسيه او لربما تخفي اثار عضويه او اسباب
عضويه هنالك اسباب عضويه تسبب ايضا اعراض
الاكتئاب من ضمنها انخفاض هرمون الغده
الدرقيه من ضمنها كذلك تغير بعض الهرمونات
بشكل عام من ضمنها طبعا الضغوط العصبيه
الضغوط النفسيه لاسباب او مشاكل اسريه او
اي مشاكل مهنيه فلهذا الامر التشخيص لن
ندعي ندعه الى الطبيب حتى الان اجتهد في
ذلك نعم
اصلا ممكن يتسلى فيها انا اعتبرها تسليه
هي يعني جزء من التشخيص السايكو مدريد
ولكن لا يعتمد عليها بشكل نهائي خصوصا انه
الاكتئاب قد لا يكون هو يعني مرض فقط نفس
نفسي
من حسب الجمعيه الطب النفسي لكن غير ذلك
لابد ان نشخص المريض او نتاكد من عدم وجود
مسببات لمرض الاكتئاب مثل هذاك الاسباب
اللي هرمونيه الاسباب المهنيه هذه هذه دور
مثلا طبيب الاسره طبيب الاسره ينظر الى
المريض بشكل شامل وبالتالي يشخص الاكتئاب
لكن ايوه لكن ارجع اقول احنا هذا الدور
هذا دور العيادات النفسيه وبما فيها طبعا
مراكز الرعايه الاوليه مزوده بعيادات
نفسيه تقريبا عندنا يعني
حياته تتاثر
بالمستقبل باشياء مستقبليه لم تحصل بدات
اني تتاثر حياته انه بي دائما عصبي ولما
بيجلس مع اهلها وبيخسر علاقاتها مع اهله
مع عمله مع اصدقاءها يعني جوده حياته
تاثرت فهنا يحتاج الى المساعده لا اذا هو
يروح معالج شعبي
اذا كان يرى ان يذهب الى شيخ او يذهب الى
معالج نفسي امشي لا يكوي ولا يضر لكن اذا
كان يعتقد انه
لجا الى اي طريقه ماعدا طبعا احنا ما ننصح
فيه ان لا يتوجه الى الادويه والعقاقير
والمخدرات ولا الكحول هذا ولا التدخين هذا
ما ينصح فيه يعني يتجنب ذلك ولا انه ايضا
يتحول الى الكريبنج للفوت يعني مرحله اللي
هو الحزن وتعويض الحزن بتناول الطعام
وبالتالي يزداد الوزن وهذه ايضا هذه
الاشياء التي يمكن تؤثر على المراه خصوصا
مع الاضطرابات الهرمونيات وتبدا بالاكل
الزياده يزيد وزنها زياده
اكتئاب عندها والقلق وتدخل في دوامه
هو يقول انه في انخفاض في معدل الاكتئاب
ممكن ارتفاع في مؤشر القلق العلاقه بينهما
همم طبيعيه ولا المفروض يكون
للخفاض مع انخفاض
وهل في فرق بين القلقاس
يرتبط بالاكتئاب ولكن لربما ادوات التشخيص
تغيرت يعني ما كان يشخص انه اكتئاب هو
تبين انه خلق انا كانت عندي حاله 20 سنه
يكتب في ملفها ان هي عندها اكتئاب لما شخص
اختها وفق لك رايه
ظهر ان عندها اجتماعي وليس اكتئاب يعني هي
تعتبر من امراض القلب ولما غيرت العلاج
لها للرهاب الاجتماعي تحسنت وهي 20 سنه
كانت تكتب اكتئاب وكل ما تذهب الى الطبيب
بيعالجها بنفس ادويه الاكتئاب فلهذا
الموضوع
ويتطرق الى تفاصيل العلاجيه يعني لا ارغب
بالمرضى ان يجتهدون بانفسهم في التشخيص
وفي العلاج هذا اللي نحتاجه فعلا في تعزيز
الصحه النفسيه احتاج الى الوعي
تحتاج الى ان تكون هنالك عيادات الصحه
النفسيه في الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه لانها
اسهل اسهل المريض يذهب الى الحي الى طبيبه
الذي تعود ان يتكلم معه
والطبيب انه بيشخصصه انك هل انت تحتاج الى
المساعده لربما المساعده السلوكيه ما
يحتاج ان يصل الى المرحله الدوائيه لربما
هو قناعاته الدينيه والروحانيه حسن حالتي
نحن ضد اي نوع من انواع العلاج ما عدا اذا
الناس
حتى اتاكد من حاله الصحه والنفسيه شكرا لك
تحكم كثير
الاهلي الاخبار الرياضيه مع ديما محمد
السايح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا خالد
السيارات للمره الثانيه على التوالي
والخامسه في السعوديه حيث اقيم الرالي
للعام الرابع على التوالي العطيه الذي حكم
قضته على صداره الترتيب العام منذ المرحله
الثالثه تقدم بفريق وصل الى اكثر من ساعه
عن الفرنسي سيباستيانو في حين حل الشاب
والبرازيلي في المرتبه الثالثه الفرنسيه
سجل اسرع توقيت في المرحله الرابعه عشر
والاخيره التي انطلقت من الهفوف وانتهت في
الدمام
تتجه الانظار مساء اليوم نحو العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض حيث يقام كلاسيكو ريال
مدريد وبرشلونه في نهائي كاس السوبر
الاسباني على ملعب الملك فهد وكان ريال
مدريد قد تجاوز فالنسيا في نصف النهائي
بركلات الترجيح بعد نهايه الوقتين الاصلي
والاضافي بالتعادل بهدف بينما تخطى
برشلونه ريال بيتيس بركلات الترجيح ايضا
عاقبه نهايه الوقت الاصلي
بالتعادل بهدف والاضافه بهدفين واستضافه
السعوديه السوبر الاسباني في جده خلال عام
2020 وتوجد باللقب ريال مدريد بعد فوزه في
النهائي على اتلتيكو مدريد كما اقيمت
البطوله في الرياض عام 2022 وتوم وجيري
جميع البطولات مهمه للغايه لذا سنحاول
هزيمه برشلونه من اجل التتويج باللقب
الفريق المتحمس جدا للنهائي ولدي لاعبون
معتدون دائما على الفوز بالبطولات لذا اثق
بفريقيا ولديهم ميزه القوه الذهنيه واللعب
في ريال مدريد يعني انك مطالب دائما
بالالقاب بنزيما عاد من الاصابه واضاف
للفريق الكثير واعطى ناطقه كبيره
وسيساعدنا فيما تبقى من الموسم
زارنا كريستيانو في التدريبات وكان سعيد
للغايه ومتحمسا لبدء تجربته مع النصر
السعوديه بلد جميل ورائع واتمنى له
التوفيق هنا واعتقدوا انه اتخذ القرار
الصحيح
هذا اللقب يعني الكثير بالنسبه لنا خاصه
امام ريال مدريد انه كلاسيكو كبير وفي
غايه الاهميه
الان ويختلف عن الريال في الموسم الماضي
الارقام الموجوده لكي تتغير ودعني اذكرك
بانني كنت ايضا محظوظا في النهائيات كان
من الصعب الفوز على ريال بيتيس ونحن الان
بحاجه للتغلب على ريال مدريد واذا اخبرتني
كذلك ان انشيلوتي لم يخسر اي نهائي منذ
عام 2010 فهذا يحفزني اكثر لقد حصلوا على
يوم راحه اضافي بسبب ان مباراتهم امام
فالنسيا كانت قبل مباراهنا امام بيتيس
اليوم سيكون الامر اكثر عدنا لكن هذا ليس
عذرا بكل تاكيد
الهلال
في ختان منافسات الجوله الثالثه عشر من
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم وجمع الهلال 26
نقطه من ثلاثه عشر مباراه في المنافسه حتى
الان فيما يحتل العداله المركز قبل الاخير
زمان نقاط من 19 مواجهه وفاز الهلال
بمباراه واحده خلال الجولات الاربع
الاخيره فيما يبحث العداله عن فوزه الثالث
في المسابقه للابتعادي عن مراكز الخطوط
وحفظ النصر على صداره الدوري السعودي
بتعادله من دون اهداف مع نظيره الشباب ضمن
منافسات الاسبوع الثالث عشر من المسابقه
هو فشل الفريقان في استغلال الفرص التي
سنحت لهما طيله شوقي المباراه النصر رفع
رصيده الى 29 نقطه حافظ فيها على صداره
الترتيب فيما اصبح لدى الشباب 26 نقطه
تراجع على اثرها للمرتبه الثالثه في سلم
الترتيب الدوري السعودي
فاز الرجاء البيضاوي على مضيفي نهضه بركان
بهدفين دون رد ضمن منافسات الاسبوع الثاني
عشر من الدوري المغربي الرجاء حسنا اوصف
الدقائق الاخيره حيث تقدم محمد زريده بهدف
الاول في الدقيقه الرابعه والثمانين وجاء
هدف التقدم الثاني للرجاء في الوقت بعد
للضائع رفع به رصيده الى 20 نقطه هو توقف
رصيد نهضه بركان عند 14 نقطه
وفي مباراه ثانيه استعاد الجيش الملكي
صداره الترتيب بفوزه على اولمبيك خريبكه
بهدفين دون رد ضمن منافسات الجوله الثانيه
عشر الشوط الاول شهد تسجيل الجيش الملكي
لهدفه الاول عبر زكريا فاتي في الدقيقه
الواحده والاربعين واضافت اكاتي هدف
التقدم الثاني للجيش الملكي رفع به رصيده
الى خمس 25
[موسيقى]
يتجدد الصراع بين ارسنال وتوتنهام هوتسبير
اليوم عندما يلتقيان في ديربي شمال لندن
في الجوله 20 من الدوري الانجليزي لكره
القدم ويتصدر ارسنال الترتيب برصيد 44
نقطه وبفارق 50 نقاط عن اقرب ملاحقه
مانشستر سيتي فيما يحتل فاطمه المركز
الخامس برصيدي ثلاث وثلاثين نقطه
يسعروا مال التقدم الى المربع الذهبي في
الدوري الايطالي عندما يستقبل فيرونتينا
في الاسبوع الثامن عشر من البطوله ولم
يخسر ابناء مورينيو في خمس مباريات
متتاليه في جميع المسابقات وحسم تاهله
الاسبوع الماضي الى الدور النهائي من كاس
ايطاليا واسعارهما للتقدمي نحو فرق الفرق
الاربعه الكبرى في المقدمه حيث يملك احدى
وثلاثين نقطه بينما يملك فرنسينا ثلاثا 23
نقطه
باقي هذا الخبر نختم نعود الان الى الزميل
خالد
[موسيقى]
من فبراير المقبل لمده ثلاثه ايام اعمال
النسخه الثانيه من المؤتمر التقني لب تحت
شعار نحو افاق جديده المؤتمراتقا العالمي
سيشهد حضور اكثر من 700 متحدثا متحدثه في
من اكثر من 50 دوله يمثلون اهم الجهات
العالميه في التقنيه والذكاء الاصطناعي
والتحول الرقمي
[موسيقى]
سليمان المحميد شابو السعوديه يعملوا
مقيما للطعام في السعوديه
لم يولد وفي فمه ملعقه من ذهب
لكنه استطاع ان يجني الكثير من خلال تجربه
الطعام حيث يمارس الشعب سليمان المحيميد
هوايه تذوق الاطعمه وتقييم نكهات الطعام
منذ 10 اعوام
يتفاعل الطهات والموظفون في هذا المطعم مع
تعابير وجهه حين يبدا بالاكل ويتمنون
تجاوز اختبار ذائقه بنجاح اذا بدانا من
الطفوله من ايامنا الصغيره
ما يعجبني اي شيء لازم يكون الاكل بطريقه
محدده عشان يعجبني حتى ايام كان والجيران
يجيبون اطباق معينه لبيت كنت اسال الوالده
بعض الاسئله مثلا كيف الصلاه
مكونات
مطاعم همم
طبعا خاصه بدايات همم النشاط التجاري همم
نطلب من مقيم الطعام الحضور همم نطلب منهم
تقييم الطعام نطلب منهم النقد اكثر من
المديح همم نركز على نقطه انه همم وضع
المنافسين اللي ينافسون في نفس همم النشاط
التجاري
همم نطلب منهم تقييم نهائي للمنتج همم
فتاثيرهم قوي جدا يعني سواء كان المطعم
اسيويا او ايطاليا فاخرا او متوسطا فان
حساسيه التذوق قيلت سليمان لا تختلفوا
باختلاف المقادير في المطاعم هي من تدفع
لسليمان في سبيل تقييم اصنافها الجديده
ونقد جوده الطهي وطريقه تقديم الطلبات
بالاضافه الى شكل المطعم وتجربه الزبائن
وتقييم ينحدر بين همم نقطتين همم انها
تكون اساس الطبق او تكون فكره الشيخ نفسه
وشي
فلما انا اطلب طباق كلاسيكي من دون فلسفه
فانا استندى الاساسيات الخاصه للطبق اذا
فيه
اضافه من الشيف
تبين فكره او تبين توجهها للطبق هنا لازم
افهم الفكره هذه قبل ما اقيمها يشهد قطاع
المطاعم والماكولات في السعوديه نموا
كبيرا بنسبه 12% سنويا وبمعدل انفاق شهري
يتجاوز خمسه مليارات ريال الامر الذي زاد
من الوتيره التنافس في هذا القطاع واوجد
له روايه المحيميد اهميه كبيره بين اصحاب
المطاعم
من الرياض عبد الواحد الحميد العربيه
من عجائب وادي الرمه في هذه السنه ان
المياه التجري فيه في منتصف الشتاء كما
يقول خالد الزعت في تقويم متابعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من عجائب جريان وادي الرمه لهذه السنه انه
جرى في عز الشتاء اخر المربعانيه واول
الشبط والمواسم عباره عن سمات مناخيه تحدث
لفتره معينه ففشبط تنهض فيها الرياح
الماكره التي لا تستقر على جهه معينه وفي
المربعانيه تتحرك فيها الرياح الشماليه
البارده ومع دخول سهيل تتحرك الرياح
جنوبيه الملطفه والنغمه المناخيه لا تعزف
على وتره واحده بل تنتقل من وتر الى وتر
ثانيه تغيرات سريعه درجه الحراره تغيرات
بطيئه حركه الرياح عندي ساعات الليالي
والايام اعدها ما فات منها دقيقه قبل كثير
من الهوى طاح مجنون ليلى قبلنا
نشف ريقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونحن الان نعيش في اول موسم الشبط وشباط
يتسموا فيه سرعه التقلبات الجويه ولهذا
اهالينا رحمهم الله يقولون شباط ما على
كلامه رباط وبروده رياحه وتذبذبها وهذه
الرياح البارده يسمونها من بكه الحصن وهذا
التذبذب يجعل الابواب والنوافذ لها صوت
قرقعه وقالوا شباط مقرقع البيبان وكذلك
هذا التذبذب ويقطع اروقه واحبال الخيام
وقال وشباط
مقطع رباط
[موسيقى]
كتب الرابعه بالعالم
السلطه
جميع ركاب الطائره المنكوبه 72 قتيلا
اسعار الايجار سبب الاكبر
خلال العام الماضي انخفاض طفيف لمعدلات
الاكتئاب في السعوديه
وتركب لنهائي السوبر الاسباني في الرياض
ريال مدريد يلتقي برشلونه في كلاسيكو
الارض
[موسيقى]